good morning everyone I hope you're well
you're healthy you and your families are
healthy during these on the precedented
times can't believe I've said that word
already so a bit of a bit of
housekeeping and in the chat where is
that Dwayne doin so if I pronounced that
wrong you can chat in there aren't so
many questions that I give you and if
you haven't been to one of these before
you can talk in there web writers as
well what you can also do with this
really simply is ask your questions so
there'll be a at the top you'll see a
Q&A section where I've already put a
question and I send ask your questions
here so at any point that you want to
answer all questions make sure that you
do and you can do it in the Q&A section
I'm also going to do a really quick poll
today as well so you should all get that
haven't done that before but as soon as
I click start polling then I think it
should all appear in your screens so
we're going to try that shortly and so
what would be good to start with and
everyone saying morning but just just
whilst more people arrive there's just
over 50 people in here already and would
love to find out where you guys are at
the moment where you're recruiting from
I'm sure it's from your your home
kitchen table dining room table but
where are you working in your housewares
but where has become your work room if
you haven't got the privilege of having
a work office like for me it's been the
living room dining room table wherever
other people been working you can share
it in the the public chat there where
everyone is saying good morning just as
more people arrive and attend but yeah
where where the hell have you been
working from because I've I've basically
taken over the dining room table
personally so I'm not sure about anyone
else and how asked they're doing it
can I ask questions air polls perfect
call kit
Laura kitchen slash living room a
nightmare can't stop en I've actually
been right eating wise I'm not gonna lie
Claudia living room or balcony okay
balcony that is decent to have that Matt
Jones spare bedroom home office garden
yeah she got home office laughing Cody
garden or kitchen Brite home office
Angelus leaf kitchen dining room yeah
Stephen Hill kitchen table my haven't my
family haven't eaten for two days I've
lots myself okay
Jack kitchen living room as well
gardening me though I can't go outside
easily so can go outside easily sorry
awesome in the price smoking in a
recruiting business in Warrenton
actually a van driver on lockdown but
cutting my god and soak in the Sun like
a Rick love that cool so let's let's
dive into this so we're gonna go over
today really simple I want all of you to
understand why you should be considering
starting a podcast as a recruiter I
think the opportunity is huge and I'm
gonna really focus on sharing practical
tips on how you can start and how it can
help you during these times how it can
help your business development how it
can help you drive sales so just a real
mixture of a practical advice on how to
start and sounds a lot equipment and but
also gonna really focus on sort of what
my game plan would be a fast to start a
podcast tomorrow and knowing what I know
now hopefully we can have some fun
during this and as I said in my I always
say my webinars and then my sort of
workshops and when I work people I do
not want you to feel like you're back at
school so this will be interactive and I
will ask you guys questions and you can
ask your questions at any point and at
the end we'll definitely do a solid bit
of Q&A but if you submit your question
as I'm going through this and I see it
then I may answer it as well so that's
cool so why I'm gonna do I'm gonna do a
bit of a competition
on this webinar so the competition is
this if you count the number of times I
say the word unprecedented correctly
during this webinar then I will jump on
a zoom video call with you for an hour
to talk podcasting personal branding
wherever it may be
so after this if if you want to have a
go at guessing that number then just
drop me an email or so you'll have my
email through this then drop me an email
with a number and if you get it right
maybe a few of you might get it right
then I'll just do like a a what's it
when you call one of those automated
sort of just random pickers and then
we'll Booker an hour's worth of time
talking my personal or podcast and so
here out for the word unprecedented cool
so I'm gonna start with like always how
do I start my podcast this is where I'm
gonna start today because it's in it's
important for you guys just to
understand sort of the journey I've on
being on with my podcast in the last two
years so some of you may not know but I
so our hosts a podcast called the
recruitment rollercoaster and I actually
actually started as a blog so I started
the recruitment rollercoaster blog in
2017 and it started with me sort of
sharing and documenting my journey and
recruitment sort of Sharon was learning
sharing the challenges and that just
came from a guy indistinct if I'm honest
just because I had a really difficult
time in my first in recruitment and how
I got told what my first year McCrimmon
is going to be like it is very much
you're gonna earn loads of money and
just told about all that all the good
things and I thought it would be a good
idea just to share content on the actual
reality of working in recruitment the
the good parts and the ugly part so I
started a blog in 2017 and to make my
life easier on the content front after
I've written quite a few blogs I started
to reach out to recruiters and ask them
to contribute to the blog by answering
five to six questions that they would
all see answer replied to me on the
Niemen and I'd put that out as a blog so
that's how I started it so I already had
recruiters sort of sharing their
experiences their journey on in the blog
format and but that's where it started
where some of you may not know that so
again this all came from a gut instinct
so um my monster in my book was really
simple I had an hour commute to to work
and I use that time religiously to
listen to my favorite podcasts on the
way to work one of my favorite ones was
the Joe Rogan podcast and and on the way
to work one day I just got sick of
listening to the ones that I was
listening to and I was looking for other
podcasts and I thought hang on now why
don't I look for a podcast about
recruitment to see if there's anything
out there and when I looked for that
there was a number of podcasts out there
that were focused on recruitment but I
didn't think that great at all they
didn't resonate with me it was just
quite a lot of old people talking about
recruitment and it didn't resonate with
me
so um by this point I had my blog and
that was sort of the opportunity that I
saw what hanging him now wasn't I think
about turning my blog into a podcast and
that's where that came from
and so I started that's my single
bedroom that I stayed in until two and a
bit years ago which is [ __ ] mental
and so I started by recording episodes
with recruiters in my bedroom using an
app on my mobile phone that that's where
I started it and that's how I started it
it was yeah it cost nothing just my time
and I did this when I returned from work
after work and I started to interview
recruiters in the recruitment industry
for my podcast so I started in my
bedroom on my mobile phone at the
beginning no one was listening obviously
where it is now is snowboarding it's
build momentum but at the beginning
honestly I wasn't I was getting anywhere
between 20 to 50 listens per episode so
I just want to make it may it's easy to
sort of look at things now I'm Vinod
really well well it looks like it's
doing really well but at the start I
wasn't getting much traction at all so I
just wanted to sort of show that and my
mentality which I'm going to talk about
in a sec was very much if if this
podcast can help one person or one of
that 20 people listen to it get a value
out of it then then I was happy with
that and I really had to remember that
early on the highly non listened at the
beginning I then moved to London joins
hooks on media who supported my vision
with the podcast they're an inbound
marketing agency that exclusively works
the recruitment industry and they really
helped me take it to the to the next
level and yeah we used obviously the
in-house marketing resources to sort of
level that up which is really exciting
and they really helped me propel it and
take it to the next level and then ten
months ago started my own business and
really wanted to take the podcast again
to the next level so one it's a partner
of a business to help me take it to the
next level and they're the guys that
hunted and and yeah Ben obviously it's
really helped me in the last time on my
own business which I'm going to go on to
and also at Hawk so media as well but
it's been on an obviously different
journey and it continued to snowball and
build momentum so two years on been in
it for two years now 100 just over 150
episodes but it really starts a build
momentum it's been listened to over a
hundred thousand times
currently reaches anywhere between sort
of fifteen seventeen thousand recruiters
a month and has been listened to in 114
different countries which just
absolutely baffles me that that those
numbers and the amount of people that is
is just mental to me and Stephen Hill I
will be able to take I'll be able to
yeah I'll share there the slides after
this just sure they said that sorry and
be yes so it's bill it's built momentum
right so from where it was and then last
year and started I actually turned this
into some some events as well did the
first one in November which was awesome
which sold out in three days and that
was a really good evening and then plan
to do it end of March another event
which obviously had to postpone which is
a real shame due to the coronavirus but
it's there men that I've been the
doing quite a lot of on quite a lot of
these online webinar events as well so
definitely a silver-lining than that so
just a quick one how does it help me
make money sounds great but okay how is
this gonna help me Hisham which I will
go into but how it's helped me
personally is when I was at Hawkes a
media it was the the best business
development tool so I would be cool and
recruitment businesses and be talking
and basically saying I don't torture
about your marketing I want to talk
about how open you be to getting
involved in in the podcast that we host
so off the back of that easily signed a
number of clients that will work six
figures to the business easily and how
it's helped me more recently is that
it's easily generated 10 grands worth of
business if not more to my own business
now and it's it's just massively how it
but for me the great the best thing with
it which I'm going to go into is the
business development element and being
able to talk to people with the sort of
intentional getting them on the podcast
and good recruiters right build rapport
build relationships and by the end of
that podcast or when you when you meet
them sit down with them or whatever what
do you guys do this it's gonna it's
going to lead to that and it's really
effective but that that's how it's
helped me personally so why should
recruit a start a podcast so I want to
show obviously this review today I've
learned a lot sort of from my sort of
two year journey with this which I'm
gonna go into you today so just very
quickly some stats that should hopefully
catch your eye I'm gonna do a poll in a
second but these are just really
interesting stats right around 7.1
million people in the UK now listening
to podcasts each week it's a lot of
people one in eight people and that's an
increase of twenty four percent over the
past year and I'm what's really
interesting is more than double over the
past five years of community s so Ofcom
research also found that half of
listeners have joined the podcast wave
in the last two years so that that's
really interesting that obviously in the
last two years it's really picked up and
people obviously got onto this so it's
clearly building momentum and then
that's just the UK in a matter
it's even bigger like crazy in 2020 for
the first time all in a hundred million
Americans listen to at least one podcast
each month that has a lot of people so
in 2017 24 percent of American 12 old
enlisted the podcast monthly compared to
37 percent in 2020 so you can see the
increase there that's in America and
then obviously 7.1 million people in the
UK so crazy growth there's a good chance
that your clients and candidates are
listening to podcasts right so I'm gonna
do this poll quickly so hopefully this
should work really simply so I'm
assuming you it may have all popped up
now so how many podcasts do you listen
to a week let's just find that out and
we can talk about this because this
would be interested in so everyone
that's obviously watching this now and
how many podcasts do you listen to a
week and I'm gonna tell you all to what
the results are okay okay so by yeah
over 40 responses no sorry over 40
people have said that it's I listened to
one free podcast a week it's quite a lot
right which is really interesting
six of you don't listen to any but so
that's interesting you're here learning
about how it can help you as a recruiter
if you're not listening to any podcast
right now you need to be doing that
especially if you're not obviously on
this webinar as well so that's really
interesting so the majority of you
listen to yeah one two three podcasts a
week right there's a good chance that a
lot of your market of definitely around
that as well so for me from a recruiter
perspective the key benefits which I'm
gonna expand on and we spend on some of
these in the next couple of slides at
the following it will honestly become
your new favorite biz develoment all
they've become a really unique candidate
engagement tool it's hundreds ain't
gonna help contribute to building your
brand in your market it's gonna really
enable you to have a unique opportunity
to build authentic relationships with
people in your market as well and it's
gonna help you make more money I haven't
put in there you'll enjoy it like you
should enjoy it if you're a recruiter
then you should enjoy building
relationships speaking to people and a
podcast is exactly that so that's that's
that's probably the final point I put on
there is that one I've really enjoyed
there enjoy meeting new people speaking
to people and it's also just men I've
met people that I've become good friends
with that become mentors that I've ended
up working with or whatever but for me
they're the key benefits so I'm gonna
expand on business development can
engagement and a few other things so for
me why is this a great business
development tool it's it's really simple
is that like you can actively
proactively reach out to clients target
clients existing clients whatever it may
be but if we're talking about new
prospects
I guarantee because I've done it I
guarantee you will have way more success
reaching out to new potential clients
with the approach of look I don't a
speech about hiring I don't a speech
about recruitment and how open would you
be to getting involved with a podcast
that I've started and how open you be to
get involved with that rather than what
all your competitors are gonna be armed
with which is have you any hiring
quirements on introducing myself or
getting referrals whatever but for me
you will get way more yeses if you go
with this approach or with a podcast or
if you have a podcast then you will
knows when I've helped people over the
when I've helped people over the last
couple of months which I'm gonna go into
in terms of helping them start their
podcast they've been really surprised
with this the amount of people that say
yes and this is really effective so if
you get way more people saying yes and
you get in front of more people
face-to-face or at the moment over video
then I guarantee you that is gonna lead
to business so for me you will get way
more yeses with a
cast as this development all Canada
engagements all so I'm gonna go into
solve this ties into part the game plan
but for me being able to head hunt
candidates equipped with a podcast that
you've recorded with a business that
you're recruiting for is so [ __ ]
powerful so for me if you can reach out
to people do the normal should be taught
some about the business that are there
and you can say look don't take my word
for it listen to this podcast let me
know what you think and this is really
effective if you've got podcast and I'm
gonna go into the game plan in the sack
recorded with people that you'd actively
recruit for that is such a unique piece
of digital collateral that you can use
to engage with candidates in your market
and it's going to do the selling for you
essentially if you then proactively put
that out to candidates who you're
speaking to
it speaks about the company blah blah
blah and they listen to that and they
really buy into the story they really
buy into the sort of people behind the
business or whatever
and what they learn on that podcast I
guarantee you one if they go away and
listen to that podcast there and engage
candidate and two if they listen to it
and they like it they're gonna be way
more engaged as well candidate
engagement tool super effective so
podcast game plan that lets sort of
transition into how I would actually
execute this so for me what's really
important is why do you want to start a
podcast well understand like anything
understand and why you're doing it is
really important and yes we would want
it to help you with your recruiting
efforts and how you make money but like
what is the sort of mission behind this
podcast and that's really going to help
you when you may feel like the beginning
that no one's listening or it's not as
getting as much traction as you'd like
so just really understanding what your
mission is with the podcast it's that's
a lot for me that was uncovering the
true failure successes and learnings
from recruiters and recruitment business
owners and that mission was really
simple is because all of you will know
that if you went to when the pubs are
back open if you went to the pub and you
bumped into recruiters one you may not
want to speak to them anyway but to if
you think I can speak to them and you're
like yeah so how's work going blah blah
blah they were just going to hit you
with yes
going great when in reality they might
blanked for the last three months
right so for me it was all about
creating a place and on this place of
actually the reality of working in
recruitment so for me if you're really
thinking about starting a podcast like
just just have a make the time to think
about why you wanna start this podcast
what's the mission with it is it
uncovering other know women leaders in
tech is it uncovering the future tech
entrepreneurs in the tech market don't
know but really aren't just really try
and think about why you want to do it
and they have a bit of a mission around
that that's going to help you really
push through when you may think not many
people listening and this will also help
when you sell it to potential people
getting on the podcast and sort of turn
them what why you've started it I think
it's really important to make it really
clear as to what your purpose is we're
there especially when you speak to
people about getting them on the podcast
and saying look I understand it but this
is why this one started I want to bring
more attention to the property industry
because I feel like not many young
people are being communicated to to get
into industry on create the place where
young professionals can look at the
property market and learn from some of
the best property professionals in the
market
wherever may be right and people will
buy into that if you know what that is
so have a why to start your podcast and
then just really basic me like basic
marketing I've gone over this in the
personal branding piece but like who'd
you want to listen to the podcast it's
just were thinking about that for me
it's really simple you can make some
clients if you're thinking about
starting a podcast it has to be for your
mark it has to be for your market like
yeah it just has to be for your market
unless it's just for personal reasons
and it's a personal endeavor that you
want to do but for me if I was in your
shoes and I wanted this to help me in my
recruitment there some are aluminum role
it has to be for your market so for me
the ideal listener is candidates and
clients but then you could break that
down to maybe sort of junior people
coming into the industry or it could be
just senior people potentially but just
think about sort of who you want to
listen to this podcast and make the time
to do that when you think about why
you're starting it and that's going to
have you understand sort of how you want
to approach it the questions that you're
not asked and that's just going to form
make sure that you execute this podcast
the best as you can so think about who
you wanna listen to the podcasts so
again guys if any of you have some
questions through this as I'm talking
just just click just make sure that you
ask them and I'll answer them
okay so practical advice on executing a
new podcast this I'm gonna go into just
some real practical advice here so for
me do not name your podcast your
recruitment agency no do not do that the
reason why is because you want to make
sure that whatever the recruitment name
is and sorry
whatever the podcast name is you want to
make sure that when I see that podcast
though I know it's made for me so a lot
of recrimination sees that's not gonna
be the case right so if you're starting
a property podcast make sure that if I'm
thinking about who you want to listen to
it if a canonical client sees your new
podcast and the name can sort of
communicate are that's made for me that
is what we want him that obviously the
recruitment rollercoaster that for me if
you're in recruitment and you see a
podcast name called the recruitment
rollercoaster you should I'd like to
think that you'd know that that might be
for you so that's really important don't
call it your recruiting agency name
instead what you want to do is call call
the podcast name whatever and then
basically what I've told a lot of people
doing this is a really subtle way of
doing it because you want your
recruitment agency attached to this
obviously but a subtle way of doing this
is sort of putting it in on the on the
sort of artwork and letting people know
that it's powered or supported by your
recruitment agency and I've got a couple
of examples for you in a second but I
think also calling it your recruiting
agency name you don't want people to
sort of thing are so [ __ ] recruited
on the podcast like that it's just gonna
fill up going to be full of sales
pictures and stuff like that so for me
make sure that the podcast name really
demonstrates and communicates who this
podcast is for and then you can add this
sort of subtle powered by supported by
sponsored by your recruitment agency so
a couple of just a couple of examples in
that are these and these are ones that I
had some sort of input on on how
and then execute so on the on the that
should be your left fun of services
podcast with Tony Bates you can see in
the bottom left pad bar idec's which is
a financial services recruitment
business you got Ellie in the middle the
journey of a wit which is women in tech
and again you can see they're sponsored
by a transition sponsored by sponsored
by transition partners
they'll say that my songs be fine sorry
guys if I'm lagging it should be fun so
if I'm lagging apologies and but in the
middle you got sponsored by transition
partners again saying something you're
completing money okay call if I'm
lagging guys I'm being really slow
can you just message on the public chat
I hope not
thanks for the question has been the
nice again okay cool
all right I'm gonna crack on with this
so and then on obviously on on the right
you've got a nice fine now okay cool
cheers thank you mate
cheers for that guy's cool so and if it
was lagging a bit so yeah you got
sponsored by transition partners in the
middle then you got and obviously on the
right hospitality hi podcast powered by
the team at be recruitment so again you
can see that they could have just called
it be recruitment podcast or transition
partners podcast or idec's podcast but
instead they've done supported by
powered by whatever right that's a
really subtle way and to do that and
it's really effective so let me just
look at and these questions that you
sent me
just in case there were so you work in
so Ben brown and just asked how
important is it to segment your market
beyond just the sector you work in good
question I think again this comes down
to the intention of your podcast life
depending on what your objective is like
if you have a recruitment this and you
really want to start sort of dealing
with senior people in your industry and
you think a podcast could help you
penetrate that then then you can segment
it to just c-level people that you that
you get onto this podcast so for me been
what I would think about
is like again who is the ideal listen
here or who do we want this to impact or
how how can this best possibly help me
as a recruiter so for me it's just
taking a step back and thinking right
how do I want is to impact my own
recruitment desk if that is I want to be
speaking to all of the junior developers
in the tech market then segment your
podcasts for junior developers or
whatever so that that I would just think
about sort of how you want it to help
you as a recruiter and then let that
guide you and unless you're Tegel it's
it is it Alicia Alicia sorry mate
I always get always get that confused
but she asks how do you get sponsorship
did you reach out what did Hunton come
to you good question
I reached out to them as simple as that
so by that point or she gained a bit
traction I had some good numbers and
these types of things and then I
proactively I had the list of people I
had like hunted I had bullhorn on there
I had other companies there I fought how
beneficial would it be for them if I've
got an audience of recruit ISM
recruitment business owners listen to
the podcast and I just practically
reached out to them bit of business
development that's how I did that and
then Ciaran asked cueing McAndrew asked
if our candidate pulls graduates for
example and our clients our recruitment
agencies who would you begin the initial
podcast engaging with okay interesting
so I think I think you could be both
there I think Karen would be the answers
so for me if I can be postgraduates Rose
on when our clients are eliminated cease
so for me actually for me actually why I
would do is I would really bring to life
graduate stories so if your clients are
eliminated steers I would find out I
would find all of the grads that you've
placed over the last year two years four
years or whatever and I'll get them on
the podcast and I would be uncovering
their story of becoming a grad a broke
grad to a decent recruiter
that's how I would do it and then the
animal see the advantage is that you're
see cultivating engaging with an
audience that you can help and then also
when you're speaking of recruitment
agencies it's then like look we can get
you involved in the podcast everyone's
come on we have grads listening or you
can simply use it to say to recruiting
agencies that this is why you should use
ours or this is why you should retain
that as this is why we should be
exclusive is because part of our
strategies is that we have hundreds of
graduates listen to our podcast on a
monthly basis hope that helps
okay right so I'm gonna crack on with
this right cool so and practical advice
to execute new podcast and if I was in
your shoes right so in unprecedented
times I would star this podcast remote
now ideally for me if we were to sit
that if I was to sit down with you free
four months from now I would say we want
this face-to-face and ideally because
then you can sit down with them and it's
a bit more authentic you can really get
to know them by blood but obviously with
what's going on now then you want to do
this and remotely which has huge
positives which does mean that people
are going to be more accessible which
I'm going to go on to but also it means
that I'd like to think has a bit more
flexibility with people that you want to
come on with their Diaries rather than
sort of trying to work out the
face-to-face diary me come to your
office you come into our office or
whatever which sometimes that can cause
so for me and if I were to start a
podcast tomorrow it would be remote I'm
gonna go into some of the things as to
the tools that you can use to do that
but remote is absolutely fine and I will
start it remote the format of the
podcast this is how I would approach it
so for me it's just got to be really
simple like for me I think as recruiters
like the intention would be to uncover
their stories like a bit like mine which
is all about just uncovering people's
journeys so if I'm a tech recruits our
property recruits are wherever it may be
for me it'd be about uncovering the
stories of the people that you have on
the podcast in your industry so for me
that's that's what the format needs to
be so it's going to be all about so if
I'm sitting down with you've all got
heard Luke Luke coverage and he's a tech
professional in my market I'm a tech
recruiter for me the format the podcast
would be
all about Luke how did you get to where
you got to how did you overcome the
challenges how did you get into the
industry what made you want to get into
the industry and then even and then talk
about you'll know better than me your
market if there's topical things that
you should be discussing if it's clove
in nineteen how are people with that and
why now that can also be a segment if
you start it this week or tomorrow
whatever
but and then you can just tie in and
topical topics like how can get more
women in our industry how can we engage
more young people in our industry or
whatever it may be but for me the format
just simply needs to be discussing their
sort of career journey and their story
and bring into life that that that for
me is just a really simple format that I
feel like all of you should be able to
do and that will generate some really
cool stories and then you can plug in
and know certain industry topics or
important topics that you know that
people want people's opinions on so I
hope that helps and that also helps
which I'm going to the editing part as
well which I'm gonna go into really
practical advice on this part I would
not publish any episodes until you've
recorded at least five so the reason for
this is because you want to give
yourself breathing space trust me
there'll be nothing worse than getting
your first podcast recorded releasing it
publishing it and then you're like [ __ ]
I need to get someone else butts in to
do the podcast next week or whatever
like you don't put yourself in that
position it's a lot for me personally I
always trying to have like a bank of
like three to five episodes that I have
recorded that if I do have a really busy
week or I can't book anyone in then I've
obviously got those that I can share so
I would I would do that and and yeah I
would record at least five before we
publish any and then you've got five up
your sleeve and you can decide how how
consistent you are with it if that's
once a week once every two weeks that
you published them and Michael Muir just
said would you give them the questions
beforehand good question so for me what
I did early on is that I really didn't
want people to have like scripted
answers or as I said are for me personal
really want it to be honest answers and
just honest conversation and I would
really encourage all of that
you guys as well but what I would do to
make people feel more comfortable and a
bit more at ease what I used to do is I
would give people the first and second
question that I'm going to ask and maybe
potentially the very last question I'm
gonna ask so what you could say
microwaves look this is my so why don't
say to people and I help them is that
remember this your podcast like you set
the rules just important remember that
so if you've got someone being like
really are see and they're just making
it difficult before you even done the
podcast then just say that I don't think
this is gonna work this is how I want to
do it like you have every right said
this is my podcast this is how it works
but what I would do to make people feel
more comfortable say look I don't give
you all the answers because this is an
open honest conversation this is how the
podcast works so what I will do is just
send you the first two questions I'm
going to ask so you know what they're
gonna be and I'm gonna tell you the the
very last question I'm gonna answer as
well and that would would obviously and
help them feel a bit more comfortable
and but yeah for me don't release any
podcast episodes until you've recorded
at least five that would be my advice so
in terms of a game plan which this ties
into making helping you bill money and
yeah we want this to help you in your
recruitment job so for me if I was in
your shoes and also starts tomorrow this
would be my game plan in terms of the
guess which is really important which
ties in to making sure this this
demonstrates and achieves return on
investment as quickly as possible so the
first five episodes I would get existing
clients so what five clients right now
do you make a lot of money out of and
the that you have a good relationship
with two reasons why this is important
and why would go down this rear the
first reason is because one I'd like to
think you have a good relationship with
them so if you start with five people
that you already have a relationship
with I'd like to think you're going to
be more console within the podcast and
they'll enable you to hone in on your
podcast interviewing skills with people
that you have a relationship with the
second thing is that back to my
candidate engagement piece if you start
with five businesses that you make a lot
of money out of that podcast episode can
then be used either straight away or a
soon
you start obviously recruiting loads
arose from again and to headhunt the
staff it's another thing that you're
going to have up your sleeve to
encourage people to work for your key
client two reasons hone in on your
podcast interviewing skills with people
that you have relationship with and also
start with start with businesses that
you have that you have a good lationship
with and that you can use to engage with
candidates for them it's just another
thing that you can add besides you've
been working for a while you know them
you play for loads of people with them
etc etc and also it's just a good thing
to do the existing clients it's just
another and it will make them feel
special right and and it's in their
interest start with five clients that
you have a good relationship with and
you're making money out of and then the
next step then then what I would also do
is then map out ten target clients so
I'm sure you will fall about who you'd
love to be working with ten target
clients you want to get in with map
those out get on the phone and try and
speed see people that's on the phone or
features direct messaging and reach out
to ten target clients and ask them about
getting involved with your podcast first
five existing clients next ten target
clients that's how I would structure the
guest list and then I'll see if you have
more existing clients you can add on
that then the next one five Fort Lee
ders in your market I really do not like
the term thought leader huh but what I
mean by this is that you wanna if you
get five people in your market they'll
already have a great reputation and you
should know who these people are so
people that already have a great brand
have a lot of eyeballs and Industry and
ultimately people that would like that
people in your market would love to
listen to you if you can get five of
those you're going to be in a strong
position to gain traction quite quickly
and the reason for this and this is
really effective what I found out guys
over the last two years is that you're
always one or two episodes away or two
guests away from your podcast just up in
the visibility and up in the reach but
if you have one or two guess that that
have a brand you're ultimately going to
be piggy and bat piggy and back off
their brand and well that means is that
these people going to listen to a
podcast not because they only listen to
your podcast but they want to listen to
other know and Liz's story because she
has a great brand in the tech space or
whatever then why I keep saying tech but
um so yeah for me get five four leaders
in your market that people would love to
learn from listen to their story and
that's going to give you the best
possible chance of gaining traction
quickly because we can piggyback off
their brand so first five existing
clients ten target clients five forty
eaters if you get those in your first
twenty episodes recorded I guarantee
you're going to pick up momentum quickly
and gain traction quite quickly as well
so that would be my real practical
advice on the guest side that will also
tie into business development and just
yeah recruit will create and welcome
helping you so Ellen fires women get
into questions but equipment listen real
practical by so I'm gonna send this
slide deck and these are all links but
honestly equipment so I've just got the
remote equipment list here and it's
really simple so the software that you
can use obviously everyone's using zoom
or Microsoft teams or whatever you could
use that Skype and I did a podcast on
someone else's the other day with a
website called clean feed which is
really good you got and software
solutions like Zen caster what I started
with anchor and there's loads of
software that you can use and that you
can use that will be yeah that you can
start with straightaway so for me that
that's fine I personally use zoom and I
think it's absolutely fine I think it's
great and so for me that's a software
that you guys could use on that and just
my personal preference and maybe this
will help you guys is that for me I find
it easier to do it over video I've been
on some people's podcast where we'll do
remote and it won't be a video would
just be like a voice call and I just
found that a bit more difficult to sort
of build rapport so I would go with so
with software that enables you to
actually jump on a video call you can
see this person because one I feel like
it can help you have a better
conversation and two it's in your
interest you get more face time right so
that's the software then you have loads
of different podcasts hosting platforms
I'll use buzzsprout which is absolutely
fine really simple and all of these poor
girls hosting platforms basically all
they do is they host your actual
podcasts and the audio that you upload
to it and then when you upload the audio
and it distributes it to all the
important places as soon as it's
published and it sets without a pad you
set it up the account that's really easy
to use is not rocket science microphones
so I'm using today the first one that I
included the blue Yeti microphone but
you don't have to get a microphone there
they are inexpensive USB microphones so
that Sam so the blue Yeti one I think is
100 quid the Samsung one is under 100
quid the road USB mic is around 100 quid
mark as well but yeah it could be worth
getting a USB microphone and it's were
left in that or if you really wanted to
you could just buy some Apple white
headphones the what the ones that just
have a microphone on this that that's
more than fine and they'll be fine just
don't use your laptop microphone as in
like just just this laptop so don't
don't not plug anything in and issues a
lots of microphone because quite frankly
I think it sounds share and that yeah
it's quite inexpensive to buy some USB
microphones so that that's how our
editing the podcast now you may be
really worried about this ie I
personally so what I did is I didn't one
I've learn how to edit tip myself but
it's really not easy because I've I've
helped myself and what I mean by that
how I've done that is because of the
format of the podcast and poor Mickey
left is asked so if I pronounced your
something wrong and when you move from
anchor to another hosting platform I
presume you didn't lose previous episode
and day to now so yeah if you start with
like anchor for example or you start
somewhere else you can then transfer it
really easily so yeah they pull through
all your episodes if you already done
them so pull the answer is no then lose
anything it pulls it through
but Edison the podcast guy is if you're
worried about this and for me and the
how you format how you do in terms of
the format of your podcast this will
really help so obviously my format has
been just locking on it just an open
conversation around there sort of
journey in their career so if you think
about your former and do it in a smart
way it would help you on the editing
front so for example if your format is
yeah so for 30 minutes we're going to
talk about so your career today at blah
blah blah
and it's just a sort of conversation
about uncovering that then you shouldn't
need to light edit loads of things when
it made to be difficult is that if you
ask like a question they answer it then
you stop in and then and the guest goes
are that was rubbish that whatever and
you keep stopping and start in but for
me what I did from the very GetGo is
just have an open honest conversation
for 15 minutes 20 minutes five minutes
and then it obviously went to 60 minutes
and that helps with the editing thing
because and then it's it's there's not
much editing today after but what I did
do at the beginning is just used really
simple freelance websites like Fiverr
which I'm sure a lot of you should know
or up work there's loads of people in
there that will edit your podcast audio
for like 20 quid a pop cost nothing you
could probably find people cheaper as
well what I now use is a piece of
software called
ala 2 which is just so easy to use and
it automates a lot of it but for me just
think about the format of the podcast
and that will really make your sort of
editing requirements a lot easier so
just just be smart with that to help you
out on the editing from so before I go
and see Q&A guys so I can see a few
questions in there so I'm gonna go into
them but if you have questions ping them
in the Q&A section I'll rattle through
them before we finish but for me star
and you will improve that that's really
so if you listen back to my first ones
they weren't great I wasn't very great
as quite robotic and you get better at
it right so what I've had to get better
at is digging deeper so when you ask a
question and people give you like a high
level answer I've had to get better at
digging deeper into what they said and
like
what do you mean by that or can you
elaborate on that or whatever that's
what you get better at but if you start
you'll improve but back to my advice on
starting with people that you have a
relationship with that will really give
you the best possible chance of sort of
being authentic and just being you with
this instead of you being sort of really
robotic and nervous or whatever so I I
would basically start and you'll learn
and improve but no my best piece of
advice when you start is like
over-prepare if i think of my first 10
to 20 episodes i would have I would make
15 to 20 minutes
to prepare for that specific guest look
at their LinkedIn look at their journey
blah blah blah and come up with
questions I basically go to that podcast
episode with maybe 10 to 15 questions
prepared so then if the conversation was
going a bit stale or I just noticed it
was going to be off of another tangent
or I wanted to make sure that I asked
them about a specific topic
I had a banker questions that I could
rely on so I'd really encourage you all
to do that over prepare for their first
couple of episodes and go to these
podcast episodes nor the script but with
a bank of questions that you can lean on
and rely on so if the quit if the
conversations going a bit stale where
it's going in the tangent you don't want
to know you want to bring it back to
where you want it to be you can lean on
those questions whenever you need to so
that that would be my best invite advice
but ultimately star and your improve
like like anything and you'll learn from
what went well from the first one to the
second one et cetera so the opportunity
but for me just to sort of wrap this up
is like right now I couldn't think of a
better time like people way more
accessible people are at home I'm gonna
have a bit more flexibility and for me I
think people are even more willing to
help others out right now so I think it
could really help you with your sort of
BD activity right now which I'm sure is
difficult and you stand in touch with
people and these types of things or you
might be being told to F off during
these unprecedented times how can you
call me when and all of this is going on
or whatever but ultimately if you start
calling people to say look I've decided
start a podcast I want to make sure that
I'm sort of doing my part part of it is
gonna mean sort of
valuable advice around this current
period but we're also gonna be talking
about your career in these types of
things I think there's a great
opportunity so I generally think there's
a real opportunity right now to take
action on this and and it'll work so the
most common questions asked I've got a
slide there but let me just look at the
Q&A guys okay Claudia gassim can you use
iMovie I'm assuming that's to edit and
I've never used iMovie in terms of to
edit audio but I'd like to think that
you can because I use like the paid
version of iMovie called Final Cut Pro
and I use that for ages so Claudia I
would like to see I like to think that
you can but honestly I think there's a
really popular one called audacity that
I've never used and that's free but yeah
don't be too worried about the editing
from Claudio what he used for Edison yet
so I've answered that Sophie e has said
how many questions do you normally ask
so for me and I'll be honest with you
all and when I started that when I
started the when I started the podcast I
I was like right so what what's going to
be the objection to people saying Hisham
you out there and for me dealing with
recruiters I'm cream and business owners
it was they're gonna they're really time
poor so for me and I I would say to
these people when I very first started
it's only gonna be a 15 minute
conversation so I started with that and
obviously 15 minutes sounds way better
than 60 minutes right so for me when it
was like early on I would probably go to
the podcast episode Sophie with at least
10 to 15 questions up my sleeve and the
conversation it's a so it's just a
flowing conversation so I don't know
exactly how many questions I normally
ask but I would go to these podcast
episodes with at least 10 to 15
questions that I had prepared or and
wanted to ask so I hope for the answers
your questions Sophie
so michaelm you are the main focus is on
the niche how often would you drop in
more generalist topics look I think
again and Michael it's completely up to
you I think if right now Coby
there's a general topic let's talk about
if right now it's mental well-being if
it's exercising or I don't know whatever
it may be a hundred percent like if you
want to make sure there's always always
like a human segment then 100 percent
include that again it's your podcast you
do what you want but definitely having
just a general topic to give people
listening an opportunity to understand
what their views are on certain generous
topics then definitely why the hell not
Stephen Hill what would you say is the
best equipment to buy for the podcast
well right now obviously remote you want
to either buy lockers oome license which
is like twelve fighting quits then you
can be on the video call for more than
forty five minutes and then for me I
personally I would buy a USB microphone
I would do that because I would want the
sort of audio quality to be as good as
it can be my end so that's what we need
to buy at this stage I'm no sorry
actually you needed wanna buy and then
you would want to buy a podcast hosting
platform like buzzsprout or pod bean or
whatever one of those in there they're
really inexpensive as well you're
talking like twelve fifteen dollars a
month so I've seen as a McCown USB
microphone and a podcast hosting
platform that's what I would say Steve
Steve Dahle working in tech how do you
decide and make sure the content is
relevant and adds credibility to your
personal brand so what I would say Steve
is that like and this is what I've
really had to remember like the podcast
isn't about you so what I mean by that
is like it's your job to get the best
out of the guest and that's the content
and that's what's going to make it
relevant and add credibility so what's
going to add you credibility Steve as a
tech recruiter and will help build your
personal banners that you're asking good
questions for me that that's like that's
what you'll get really good at so it's
about asking the questions that the
audience want you to ask so that's
that's how you're going to make sure
that sort of your you're building
credibility in the content stays
relevant that would be my
answer to that who did it
okay right so how you keep never said on
two platforms listen Liz never has said
I've started podcast how have you kept
it going for so long topical platforms
and generalist okay so I'm just gonna go
with keep it going for so long so I have
four obviously I've done that over 150
episodes now I'm like are people gonna
get bored of this but for me what I
would do is play around with it so if
you if you think what one you're gonna
have to be consistent but two to play
around with it why I've done a couple of
times is do you like for a period I did
like quickfire episodes so I did sort of
short short episodes compared to the 60
minute episodes and I think for me
layers honestly don't underestimate how
how much people love to hear about
people's stories and honestly everyone's
story will be different the questions
might be the same but the answers will
be different so and keep going you you
need you need to stay consistent but
don't underestimate sort of how much
people generally do really enjoy
people's stories and that's what I'd say
to that so when I suppose the time 11:52
okay cool run ask answer a couple more
and we're gonna finish this so right I'm
gonna answer some of the most common
ones I know some of the questions that
come coming in so I'm gonna do this okay
cool
so it's a question from Jack at cobalt
was and like how long should it be and
I've just been talking about this then
but for me if you're worried about
people saying I don't to do it because
I'm too busy then maybe got leaned with
five minutes I think that's a good
amount of time for use awesome good
question and that's some good
conversation but do not underestimate
how long you can have a conversation for
that's what I definitely found all of
mine now or like 60 minutes long I think
that's a great time it's Orsi good
community although no one's commuting
now joining is unprecedented times so
like for me yeah I think they're both
decent I've listened to something along
some of that ashore
so there's no like perfect time a
question from Leif sw6 how do you
monetize the podcast for me if I was a
recruiter it's about like focusing on
the businesses that want to be working
with so you'll be surprised how quickly
that you can either sign a client off
the back and then come on your podcast
and - and a candidate listen to your
podcast and then say like do they have
any jobs there or using the podcast to
engage with candidates for a role you'd
be surprised how quickly it can help you
on that front so for me the monetization
of the podcast is Sahn and clients and
using it to engage with candidates
you'll be surprised how quickly that
happens and I've had clients that I've
helped to their podcast that they've
achieved both those things in five
episodes like so do not be surprised how
quickly this can help you and then
question from Alex more like Anna Jarvis
how long until you feel you get traction
and how quickly did you see ROI it's a
lot for me I would say after after
twenty or so episodes I'll really
started to build traction and and then
it just kept build in so doing 20 30
episodes from that point you rich should
really start to build traction and
engagement and and build momentum
because obviously what you'll find is
that once you've done 20 30 or more then
obviously the benefit is if someone
finds your podcast tomorrow and there's
a bank of 20 30 episodes to listen to
that's going to rack up your listens and
rack up the the traction so I'd say 20
onwards you're gonna really start seeing
traction and in terms of how quickly you
see ROI as I said I've had a couple of
clients that have done 5 episodes and
within that letting great ROI so for me
I think that ROI with podcasts is really
quickly because if you start a podcast
tomorrow and your first 10 guests on
your target client list that's ROI easy
so for me like that's the opportunity
question from list corner log deck
recruitment how to quick I've spoken
about that
so before I finish guys let's just look
at some of these questions sorry very
quickly
Alex bluey has said
if the people I work with am BD in my
market vary from founders CGH on town
acquisition teams how do i angle it to
add value to people in different job
roles well for me what I'd think about
is what's the common thread between all
those people that they find challenging
or would be interested in a last thing
that would be some sort of common thread
there and then also what I'd maybe think
about doing alex is let you're not going
to like you're not going to make it
super relevant for all those people
that's quite a few different people
there so for me what you could do is and
what I've done recently which is quite
smart is maybe you segment that into
founder CEOs or c-level people and hate
on talent acquisition and then what you
could do alex is the sort of common
theme could be beneficial or interest
with CTOs sea level people founders and
h on talent acquisition but what you
then do is every other episode you have
a HR talent acquisition person and you
have a c-level person so for me what
I've done is I've got now a bill a
rollercoaster
so I'll get a recruiter that's a biller
and I'll focus on them so you're
uncovering their story that's that's one
episode and they'll have an agency own a
roller coaster so what that means is
alex is that when you're sitting down
with founders and CTO is your
questioning will be slightly different
to make sure it's relevant for founders
and CTOs and then when you're sitting
down page 110 acquisition people your
questions might be slightly different
tailored to be beneficial for HR and
talent acquisition people so you could
do both for the same podcast but make
sure that when you do have those
different types of people on your show
that you're asking specific questions to
them to make it valuable for the people
in that in that segment basically is
what I'd say so so for
poor cos will help with a bit with BD as
a contract recruits are yeah hundred
percent lot honestly okay actually yeah
this just come to me for those of you
that still here what I would do so feet
to test this okay is you can try
existing clients or new client or
potential new people I would practically
cool people and say I am thinking about
starting a podcast this is why what do
you think and how old would you be to
get involved see how that goes a gander
you'll be pleasantly surprised
prior to reach out to people and say I'm
thinking about starting a podcast would
you be able to get involved and do you
think it's a good idea guarantee you you
will get caught free and you would speak
to people so Sophie yes it will help you
BD because it would never you to cool
people without saying are you hiring I
want to introduce myself or whatever it
will give you a point of difference um
slip before we finish jabya lani
i will email everyone the slide deck for
the mortar to listen so don Q&A as i
said guys the competition at the
beginning of this is if you've kept
count of the amount of times that I've
said the word unprecedented and you feel
like you know how many times I said it
I've kept count myself and email me
Hisham Aziz Brandon and I will and we
can book in a time for an hour to talk
about podcasting personal branding if
you get it right
so look I have not you been able to
answer everyone's question but I will do
my utmost to get battle and answer your
questions and but I just wanted to say a
huge thank you to all of you give them
your time I really appreciate it if
you've enjoyed it let me know feedback
is very much welcome feel free to
connect me on LinkedIn if you want to
ask me any questions whatever drop me a
line or send me a message on LinkedIn
that's absolutely fine and but yeah
honestly guys really hope you enjoyed it
stay safe and enjoy the rest of your
week and and I will be doing more of
these so I'll let you know when they
come out so thanks
guys for your time